hoped digging for gold would pay for his
education
he worked as a mine in the bush here in
the central african republic
he bought a new motorbike to get there
on his way home he says militia held him
up stole it
and then told him to lie face down on
the ground he refused
i told him if you want to kill me way to
my face
as we were talking he shot me in one leg
i started screaming he saw i could still
walk
so he shot the other then i couldn't
walk
anymore the bones in moy's leg are
shattered
with it his plan to study
it was a passerby who brought moyes to
this hospital in the capital buongi
it's run by the charity doctors without
borders
the manager says many others aren't so
lucky
the armed groups who want to overthrow
the government control most of the
country
worldwide is maybe some hundreds or even
thousand people
we do not have any right figures and
during this kind of peak of violence
where everybody is more in the bush and
are not able to stay in the villages
i think that all the kind of care is
limited
the violence escalated before during and
after elections held last month
political opposition say they were
rigged
un peacekeepers russian mercenaries and
rwandan troops
support the government bongi and a bit
of territory around it
is one of the few parts of the country
that's firmly under the control of the
foreign forces that support
the government the city sits on the
banks of the river
ubongi and more than a tenth of central
africans
have fled the violence to neighbouring
countries most of them across the river
to the democratic republic of congo on
the other side
inside the country more than half of its
5 million people are in urgent need
of humanitarian assistance and hundreds
of thousands have fled their homes
saundri natalie is one of them she told
us
nothing is more terrifying than waking
up to find yourself in the middle of a
battle
when you're seven months pregnant now
she's staying here at a relative's house
at five in the morning i was woken up by
the sound of heavy weapons
they were shooting rockets i hid in my
room traumatized
i didn't know what to do when the
situation got calmer
i took my children and walked for six
hours to get to a hospital
the current crisis here began eight
years ago
when armed groups overthrew the
government of the time
that's when these people fled their
homes they've been living under plastic
sheeting ever since
the conflict has continued for as long
and so has its devastating effect on
people's lives
malcolm webb al-jazeera bongi central
african republic